make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and I
totally forgot that DC releases comics
on Tuesdays now and it's 11 o'clock at
night I totally forgot that was the case
ah so we are covering deceased hope at
worlds in part tres uno dos tres
part three here's the thing all right so
hope it worlds end this is actually
super cool right because we covered the
first two chapters of this part three is
awesome this again this takes place
between the actual issues of DC so it's
kind of filling this stuff in but the
cool thing about this too that I hope
you guys are noticing this feels a lot
like injustice right it feels a lot like
injustice gods among its the way it's
written the way that it's drawn we're
not really the way that's charged but
like the way the titling is and all that
kind of stuff it feels like like
injustice so what this does is this
answers the question if so many people
were asking including myself where is
Wally West where's wally west in all of
this okay so what this does is it
initially picked up in Keystone City
you basically have Wally kind of
responding to everything that's going on
the fact of the anti-life virus more or
less is spreading throughout the digital
space and so wally west of course
destroys all the digital items with a
screen inside the home of himself and
Linda Park and then following that like
it's immediately taking throughout the
entirety of Keystone City right like
racing through the city as fast as
humanly possible and destroying every
screen that he can find now on the
surface this does not seem impressive
but in reality it is because one thing
you have to keep in mind is that Wally
is destroying every single screen II can
find while not looking at it which is
actually a pretty insane feat in and of
itself but when you consider the nature
of the flash it also makes sense right
like literally the the you know at the
speed he moves for him it's it's almost
kind of like regular speed but it's like
it's like moving like a regular person
the way you where I move and then in
turn he's just doing it astronomically
fast that kind of seems to be the case
anyway but it's one of these things
right because he's moving faster than
thought and that's something that you
don't usually see described in terms of
the speed of Wally West but keep in mind
he's the fastest of all the speedsters
now for those of you guys who don't
understand that who don't who don't
really know how that works
um yes Barry Allen did create the Speed
Force but Wally West's main lines the
Speed Force and the reason why that
matters is because we're buried taps
into it Wally West is in effect the
Speed Force itself right he's like a
walking talking Speed Force and so he's
a he's fully imbued by the power of it
so it's all if he had to equate it so
like the lantern the Green Lantern
those Wally West is the equivalent of
like large fleas right Larfleeze does
the only orange lantern he has all that
power there wally was is akin to that
he's not the only speedster but he's
able to use a Speed Force in a way that
allows him to run faster than everybody
else and he actually has some pretty
cool feet spinning at the speed of
thought is an astronomically fast pace
right because he's able to cover he
stone city in factions of a second right
able to cover this entirety of the city
within seconds of of everything popping
off the funny thing about this though is
he described it he's almost running at
the speed of light and begins to bump up
against the speed force now this is a
benefit but also a massive drawback
Wally West has been sucked into the
Speed Force and has been able to escape
fort but the issue with this is a time
doesn't exist in the Speed Force and so
if wally west was yanked in and then
left it could be that he came out years
after all this happens right there's no
real definitive way for him to know
exactly how much time passes and a lot
of that's because a Speed Force is not
fully defined in DC Comics we don't know
everything about it we simply just know
that it's there and it's how the
speedsters get their power and people
can be trapped in it locked away that
kind of a thing more often than not
depending on who's writing the story a
person can be trapped in the Speed Force
and then usually when they escape they
get out in a reasonable amount of time
so like superboy-prime for example he
was trapped in the Speed Force for a
while did he manage to escape through
means that were never fully explained
and it was something like less than a
day when it happened right so we just
kind of you know take it for how it is
but ultimately Wally is met by a by the
voiceover of Batman now this is how we
know this seems to take place before the
death of Batman in the events of of
decease number one right so it's kind of
interesting because it seems to sort of
throw things off right this is right
when the whole thing first takes off so
I wouldn't really say that the comics
themselves are out of chronology but
because they're following each
individual character it kind of makes
sense that it would you would show us
what while he's doing at the time the
whole virus for yourself yes that's
really kind of how this has worked up to
this point and so with that being the
case what we basically have Batman
telling him look like you know you can't
let this virus take you right like you
you can't let this virus end up taking
you if it does you're gonna be a threat
to the whole world and while he knows
this ready for the most part of it's
common sense to him because of the fact
that he's a speedster he is the actual
fastest man on the face of the earth if
the virus does take him the entire earth
is going to be doomed now we know that
plays out with Barry Allen in the main
DC story itself but while he's also
aware of this you know and even Batman
goes as far as to say Barry listen to me
you know and while he's like I'm gonna
save my city I don't really care what
you have to say and Batman realizing
there's nothing he can do to stop and
basically says don't get scratched don't
look at a screen you know Wally West is
like ok thanks and Batman's like goodbye
and so that's basically the end of that
and of course as we know that's
basically the last time that you end up
seeing Bruce Wayne Bruce Wayne being
infected with the anti-life virus is
able to keep himself in stasis for a
while using the technology of Mr Freeze
but ultimately it's not perfect it
doesn't really last forever and so
wall-e begins to come to the realization
that he himself is not fast enough to
save the entirety of Keystone City right
because of the fact that the virus is
spreading so incredibly fast because you
have so many people looking at their
screens at the same time and all it
takes is a glimpse in order for a person
to basically to pick up this virus while
he can't really counter it fast enough
people are basically turning faster than
he can stop them and so because of this
wall-e needs help I said what is what
does he do he crashes into the apartment
of max mercury and Bart Allen which I
know a lot of flash fans are definitely
gonna be excited about right the idea
that max mercury and Bart Allen are here
in the story Bart Allen of course is
basically playing video games you know
or at least getting ready to turn on
play a video game not really paying any
attention
fortunately for him the screen is
basically facing away uh wall-e comes
running in destroys a laptop and then
the TV Bart Allen begins to freak out
and it's kind of interesting around the
same time max mercury begins to pick up
on the idea that that people are
screaming out there right so it's all of
them kind of coming to a head at the
same time now a little bit of
explanation here those of you guys who
were not really familiar with max
mercury Bart Allen and then of course
are actually joined by by Jesse quick
originally these were all disconnected
speedsters right in the sense that they
didn't actually share a unified factor
in the Speed Force right max mercury
originally appeared in quality comics
after Jay Garrick and he was introduced
as a character of Quicksilver right so
Quicksilver before the version that we
saw in Marvel Comics I heated up
basically kind of being a character that
was shuffled off to the background and
disappeared for decades right for
decades and decades until really Mark
Waid took over the flash mythos and then
brought him back right and then he
brought him back as max mercury uh as
far as his powers go he actually gained
his abilities from essentially a Native
American shaman who basically enchanted
him with the ability to tap into the
Speed Force at the time that he gained
his powers it was just a shaman that
allowed him to run at SuperSpeed right
it wasn't until Mark Waid wrote terminal
velocity and unified all the speedsters
through the invention of the Speed Force
that we learned that's what he was able
to do
most of you guys know is the grandson I
believe of the son of Barry Allen from
in the future the the far-flung future
jesse quicks a little more interesting
right so Jesse quick while not nearly as
fast as the other speedsters pills the
daughter of Johnny quick and Johnny
quick was basically a guy who discovered
a mathematical formula that when he said
it would allow him to gain SuperSpeed
now again because of the events of
terminal velocity in reality allowed him
to tap into the Speed Force he taught
the formula to his daughter Jesse and
now she's able to run a super speed
right so that's kind of how all these
different characters gain their powers
and it's how they're all sort of
intertwine but with regards to Wally
what he basically says is like you know
I'm gonna try to keep this thing or you
guys need to keep this thing from
spreading throughout the entirety of of
Keystone City basically destroy all the
all the screens you can I'm gonna look
for an alternative a way for us to
basically save this place as best we can
and they race through everything right
like Central City they raced through New
York they raced through Gotham City they
raced through all these different
locations and it's pretty cool you know
to see that happening because what what
takes place here is max mercury
basically says the only way to really do
this is to use the tandem cosmic
treadmill now the funny thing about this
is that Wally West basically says that
at some point in time Jay in vari had
used the tandem cosmic treadmill to open
a hole in space but as far as I'm aware
the only time that the tandem cosmic
treadmill has been used is when it was
used by Kid Flash Wally West and Jay
Garrick right they the two of them used
it in order to you know open open a rift
basically and I think was during the
events of crisis on Infinite Earths I'm
not gonna swear to that but I believe it
was they were the only ones who were
able to do that now I could be wrong
right my knowledge on DC's mythos is not
nearly as in-depth as Marvel's but
that's the only the only instance that
I'm aware of and of course they did that
because of the fact that at the time
Barry Allen was the only one who could
shift between dimensions and they
basically needed Barry right so Barry
was you know seem to have been dead by
that point in time and and things kind
of went from there but regardless of the
situation the the tandem cosmic
treadmill has to be used here in order
to open a portal to another dimension my
to another world which would allow the
residents of Keystone City to basically
be whisked away to safety to an
alternate universe and this is kind of
interesting right to see the various
speedsters come together and to
effectively not even consider the option
of getting a hold of like Superman or
anybody else and basically say like
we're just going to open a whole to
another dimension and then call it a day
is kind of intriguing right because you
would expect Wally
the other superheroes to go racing after
these guys you know the the you know to
basically say like we all need to kind
of come together but at this point the
idea of wall-e is to save Keystone right
and the only way to save Keystone the
200,000 people who were there is to open
a portal and then have the speedsters
whisk them there as fast as they can and
that's exactly what happens right this
portal gets open to another world and
the evacuation of the city begins now
we're not really given a timeframe here
other than to say that you know within
like 12 minutes 146,000 people have
basically been saved right you know like
12 minutes it happens and it released
you know it seems to happen now we can
kind of break things down and stay
within another two minutes you know that
basically the remaining 200,000 people
are saved but essentially 200,000 people
are rescued from Keystone city and the
span of 15 minutes or less roughly
that's how fast this happens and that's
why these are so cool is because all the
speedsters are coming up with these
super fast solutions and this is the
most practical one in the span is this
one of the reasons why is this a cool
concept because in the time that it
takes for the speedsters to to basically
open this portal and then race off and
basically save people I you know it's it
took the the other superheroes on earth
probably that much time to rescue maybe
like four people or five people or
something like that for all we know
that's how long you know Superman stood
talking to Jimmy Olsen in the last comic
that we read so it is it's cool to see
how fast things happen in relation to
the speedsters compared to everybody
else the problem with this is that Bart
Allen can't quite handle the rigorous
nature of running that astronomically
fast and so Bart Allen basically ends up
collapsing as a result of this you know
max max mercury is like okay you know
I'll grab Bart you keep the door open of
course Bart Allen has basically thrown
out there and you know seemingly injured
in the midst of all these people
infected with the anti-life virus max
mercury races out there he grabs bart
allen and then alongside Jesse quick
they basically end up racing back into
into the dimension into this new world
and this is kind of an important thing
right because max mercury and Bart Allen
always shared a kind of bond in the
sense that max mercury was basically his
tutor but he was he was the teacher of
Bart Allen and it's a cool little moment
here because they basically share this
this bit where it's like hey you know
I'm here to be your instructor more or
less when they really went max mercury
took over that role but he's very much a
father figure for bart allen and so this
is even more significant when when you
know of course they get to the other
side they basically you know end up
asking
only for us to find out that max mercury
has basically been scratched right now
mercury is now infected with the
anti-life virus and where bart allen
pleads and begs for for somebody to do
something there's nothing they can do
right like the virus is coursing through
his veins there's nothing that can be
done
max Mercury's doing his his end is
imminent and in fact he goes as far as
to tell Wally you have to end me now but
you have to end my life there's nothing
we can do and then Wally basically
figures out there is a way to save max
and so what he basically ends up doing
is grabbing max and then running as fast
as he possibly can
right as fast as Wally West could
possibly run which basically opens up a
portal to the Speed Force and max
mercury ends up running into the Speed
Force and there he remains right he's
just running forever inside the Speed
Force trapped he's just there and
presumably there'll be a way to rescue
him if a if a cure is ever discovered
but it could just be one of these things
where max mercury will forevermore be
inside the Speed Force never to return
again but when that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here - comments explained
make sure you guys to the sub button to
become part of the rom core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you